bella tutti ragazzi venuti cosa un video
sono va vj e la gestiamo su un altro
video che in colloqui lo slip e
videogioco di matrix con la crus richter
cioè io io non ho parole quindi ragazzi
siccome non reggo un secondo di più
perché devo assolutamente provarlo direi
che possiamo cominciare ho mancato la è
come fate a letto ragazzina o mio dio
ragazza era è una figata ragazzi è una
figata pazzesca mio dio offre l'ho presa
dunque si è presa sospetto riganò io mi
sono sempre chiesto come ci si sentisse
a trovarsi qua dentro
the matrix no c'è sfigata sono morto
ragazze 1 morto cosa in araba tipo
quella murphy
come stai 9 l'aia da un bel pezzo che
non lo vedrei marcel semioli
coreografico alessando insomma guardava
morpheus è veramente gentile tro voglio
dire proprio non stai muovendo la bocca
che cazzo fai a parlare non è normale
ragazza cosa prova becera se io guardo
tipo cosa cazzo ha fatto sono le f
possibile se mi concentro se rischio di
nuovo spettacolo di magia sabato sera a
torino ragazze stock rava addosso dove
lo mettiamo
ragazzi è una cosa ma morte o se molto
più alto di quanto immaginassi non so se
è normale provate un attimo posso
entrare nel corpo di morfeo è bellissimo
dovunque entry comunque io riesco a
vedere ancora i suoi occhiali sta cosa
non la capisco se mangia vita mia nonna
col cazzo che ci avevano stomaco vuoto
questo è sicuro fare qui tipo a parte a
parte piegare i cucchiai col pensiero
genova ho capito mi scelgo tipo livello
se faccio così no dai navigato sta cosa
la pillola blu questo qua che questo non
l'ho fatto ancora ma ci stiamo così
posso muovere tipo alla matrix ok che
succede
programma il programma di salso ragazzi
cazzo
la [ __ ] che mi chiami mi sono tutte le
parti ceca siena cosa perché no marche
ma a spider man e fa una piccola
ragazzina vi spiego un attimo questo è
il programma di saldo
cioè io in teoria dovrei riuscire a
saltare dove saltato morphine problema è
che i ragazzi è una roba tipo di un
santo ma canzone saldi stanno ragazzi
impossibile coprendo tutti i tasti h sì
ho trovato regala trovato cazzo lo sono
salito 3 2 1 murphy melo può parma ma
futuro
ma che cazzo sono il passato di potito
ok sono morto sono morto sono morto dei
corpi in un ascensore grazie perché sono
morto morto
ok che è successo sì però smettila di
fare lo spaccone perché sei penato
allora questo salta e ci riesce ho
capito mi ha detto vi farà veramente poi
facili velatamente pensiamo che ne so i
teletubbies della bis è la rai
teletubbies e lei da bis ed avvisi non
funziona i type avis tua madre
no grazie sono un deficiente ora gas è
macchiato gioco e continua a strisciare
anche mi sono spiaccicata al suolo solca
morti veramente senza pensieri senza
pensieri senza pensieri un ragazzo
rimasto mm fuori caccia macchia che culo
un santino per mika che sudata spiderman
citazioni dai temi che ha fatto il salto
che si ma tutte uguali sostanze però è
un po meno di luminosità non guasterebbe
però vabbè io entro affanculo
ok a sentono antiqua perfetto d'accordo
ragazzi o il salto lì ci ho messo 40
minuti ma non importa allora ecco premio
questo di caffè sta roba è un altro cioè
strill.it sei tu ammazza che può
permesso a rim allarmi l'abbiamo visto
il film l'altro giorno
sono la persona più felice della terra
possono fare come se fossi a casa mia a
vero tipo come all'ato ai center prendi
giocattoli dite che è successo a gente
smith e jackie che se aspettate
e quello che penso cazzo
grazie a prendere sei una stronza di
merda pro link che porta appena
possibile lo sto facendo ragazzi si no
sono morto merda povero rega è
fantastico è morto e molto a dio santo
regalato uno sfinito vedete hai visto
murphy 5 euro per lo spettacolo sembra
che questo sia l'ultimo volete chiuse
perché mi sembra così sennò ha ordinato
io la pizza ragazzi tranquilli in altre
103 ho capito vicina no non aspetta un
attimo avevo capito non aprire la porta
non aprire la porta
salve ma non c'è nessuno che ci fa lenti
zio scusami se ti ho chiamato prima
ballerina di vico york vabbè ma te la
prendi per niente se però sei un pezzo
di stronzo da prendi come niente fatto
vuol dire qualche non e non si parla
sono un po morto ragazzi se non avesse
aiutato però non fa niente ragazze si
possono irascibili non si può dire
niente
questa è la mia bravura guarda zia lo so
però preme che mi ha scaricato un
caricatore in faccia sai come mamma me
piace a tua sorella scusa che ognuna
civile è successo mi serviva perché io
sono le detto io non posso morire così
possa fargli ma perché probabilmente un
po freddo lo sento e gli appelli gelate
si sono stato luis pranzi troviamo
fermare i proiettili
non ci posso credere no lega male pc ma
quanto può essere epico sto gioco perché
io sono eletto e io posso fermare i
proiettili ma mai avviato la pizza ai
ragazzi io vedo così praticamente ho
bisogno di un paio d'occhiali cosa fa
sì ma sei un deficiente s'è schiantato
addosso tu che cazzo guardi della villa
i [ __ ]
ecco bravo ministro
da un 100 ragazze filibuster troppa
epicità in un gioco solo io mio santo
ragazzi da nova locus mi fa leggermente
sudare mi dicono tutti ragazzi è stato è
stato meraviglioso no perché veramente
per chi conosce matrix secondo me è
fatto da dio è una cosa pazzesca
comunque vado a prendere un asciugamano
se non mi dispiace perché ok con chi
ragazzi servito è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche al progetto di
facebook e come non i video trovate la
descrizione se non se l'è vorresti di
scriverli ci vediamo il prossimo vinto
belle ragazze